[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con nos acompaña
desde la ciudad de lima henry rafael
analista político y presidente del
instituto de comunicación política y
gobierno con él vamos a analizar la
crisis política por la cual atraviesa
actualmente el perú luego de la
destitución de martín vizcarra y la
asunción a la presidencia de manuel
merino señor rafael bienvenido gracias
por estar con nosotros comencemos por
las protestas mientras al interior del
parlamento se juramentaba manuel merino
como el nuevo presidente peruano en las
calles de lima centenares de
manifestantes indignados se exigían la
restitución de vizcarra como el
presidente le pregunto si hay una
dicotomía entre los intereses del
congreso y el sentir del pueblo peruano
creo que las protestas que se están
dando son naturales por supuesto
y otras incitadas por algunos grupos de
izquierda o de centroizquierda que lo
que están básicamente poniendo en
evidencia efectivamente es las
discrepancias con este congreso electo
básicamente este año en una elección
democrática y que nace justamente de la
disolución de un anterior congreso por
el ex presidente martín vizcarra aún así
se que los medios de comunicación están
informando sobre estas protestas pero se
tratan aún de protestas bastante
pequeñas en cantidad de personas
respecto a la situación de normalidad
que si se vive en el perú más allá de la
detendrán las protestas que se están
dando en algunos puntos específicos hay
una situación de normalidad que se vive
en general a nivel nacional la vida está
continuando sin que el país se haya
paralizado qué es lo que
el mundo debe ser ahora al ser
destituido martín vizcarra por el pleno
del congreso el ahora ex mandatario dijo
que no apelaría esta decisión es una
manera de reconocer que si estuvo
involucrado en hechos de corrupción
cuando era cuando era gobernador
yo creo que creo que martín vizcarra
sabe que primero la decisión del
congreso es legal y constitucional con
lo cual no hay forma de apelar algo que
ha sido evidentemente realizado con una
votación mayoritaria no se trata de una
votación congresal de una mayoría o un
límite justo no o sea el congreso del
perú tiene 130 integrantes lo mínimo
para sacar al presidente es 87 votos se
lograron 105 sólo un partido político
voto en contra son los partidos
políticos que emergieron a partir de la
elección de este nuevo congreso con lo
cual es una elección bastante sólida
pero es una decisión bastante sólida
creo que marcó y vizcarra si tiene que
afrontar a la justicia recuerden que son
cinco testigos que han dicho que eran
entregados 2.3 millones son un poco
menos de un millón de dólares en coimas
a martín vizcarra y por iu y por el
mismo equipo fiscal
ha puesto en evidencia los denuncias de
corrupción contra el ex mandatario del
perú e incluso echo fujimori
el nuevo presidente manuel merino llega
a ser presidente de perú a sabiendas que
había sido elegido para el congreso con
apenas 5.000 votos
cuánta legitimidad puede otorgar se lee
como mandatario teniendo en cuenta que
se prevé estar ocho meses en el poder
martín vizcarra tampoco llegó con voto
popular llegó como parte de una plancha
presidencial que fue electo de que fue
electo pedro pablo kuczynski el
presidente que más bien por chad que se
exprese ha tenido el habría tenido
también participación en el proceso de
vacancia contra su ex jefe por decirlo
de alguna forma yo a ver no se trata de
legitimidad por votos esto es un proceso
constitucional puede haber que puede ser
que haya tenido mucho más votos menos
mucho menos la constitución lo que dice
es que un caso si el iris de un traspaso
presidencial de una presidencia temporal
quien asume la presidencia es el
presidente del congreso porque en el
congreso lo han electo porque son los
congresistas los representantes del
ciudadano de acuerdo al marco
constitucional entonces no estamos
hablando de legitimidad por votos
estamos hablando de legitimidad por
causal constitucional que es el proceso
que hemos tenido
señor rafael gracias por su tiempo y por
estar aquí con nosotros en 5 minutos con
de france en 24 sedes a mí gracias por
siempre estar ahí conectados a nuestro
canal hasta pronto
[Música]